now pure mathematics
If you pick up a book on pure mathematics and you
look at the table of contents, you will find different.
Subtopics, but this is the one that I think.
is
as appropriate
and this is based on some.
books on pure mathematics setup come across
so sets
at the very top sets are ubiquitous to
all of mathematics.
They're not difficult to learn the syntax involved is
very minimal, but they're quite powerful topics and
many ideas have derived from from sense and
we will cover set of course in the tutorial.
Then we have logic.
the study of logic
and
something we call Pop essential calculus the calculus.
of
Truth statements
again, this is relevant to writing algorithms because
And algorithms we have control statements.
and some control statements can become quite
elaborate
furthermore
a very important skill for any mathematician
Is being able to write and understand
proofs?
well understanding propositional logic
is Central to
Being able to read and perform proofs. Once
again, we will look at proposition calculus in the tutorial.
And then we have something called an algebra. You know,
when here when I see algebra, I'm specifically referring to an allergy break
structure. If you remember in the previous slides we
talked about something called a mathematical strap structure while an
algebraic structure is a type of mathematical
structure.
things like Fields rings and groups
these words that I just brought up.
You will find in.
You you could find any mathematical literature and you
need to be able to understand what the author means when they
say for example, this is a field.
or these following elements
if your data scientist, for example
and you want to
understand how some very Advanced machine learning algorithm
works and how it is implemented.
You will.
find the formal definition of that particular model in a book or in
an academic paper and
they will inval invariably or very likely
I should say refer to.
mathematical structures that are discussed in
abstract algebra
moving on we have that something called congruence, which is
really about divisibility
and integers
And how is this relevant? Well?
in cryptography
cryptography at its core has or uses
prime numbers. And what is
the definition for prime number?
It is a number that is either divisible by itself or one.
now that is a very small insight into
our cryptography works, but
Again, this is something if you want to understand cryptography, you
have to read discrete mathematics.
And by the way, if I can just make a company in your discrete mathematics is
a subset of pure mathematics and I will
show you this hubs in a second, but let's move on very quickly. And then
we have relations and functions relations. A relation
is a description about how
two sets are well associated with each other.
and functions well
There are two ways to look at functions. There is
a map.
Perspective there's nothing we call a map which basically is
something.
A map is something that takes elements from one domain and
Maps them to an element in another domain in
another set. I meant to say so we have the domain in
the range.
Another perspective of function is something to
which you
assign arguments
and then you have some internal operation and from which you
will have an output.
And yet another perspective is that a
function is a itself is another relation. So maybe
maybe these are not helpful terms unless of
course we start writing some mathematics which
of course we will do.
Counting
or more broadly speaking combinatorics is
how we use.
Or it's about clever ideas for counting large
things very cleverly and without manual work
manual labor.
And this has a lot of applications again in
whether it's in cryptography or
compression
probability Theory
so if you if your data scientist
counting or you need to know combinatorics.
And there's no two ways about it.
Complex numbers of course complex numbers which has to with imaginary numbers
and real numbers. We're not gonna get at that today add analysis,
which is
calculus at a higher level
so it's concerned with things like Infinity Series limit
sequences.
Once again, this is something you may also want to.
put on your bucket list if you're a data scientist because in probability
Theory
there is an extension of this.
There's another branch of mathematics there is
of concern to probability Theory and probability theorists
called measure Theory.
and
measure Theory
for the prerequisite is analysis.
So really what I've tried to make up
the point of trying to get across is here
is that